unsere Recherche beginnt am Stammsitz
der Bauernfamilie Wolters im sächsischen
Döbeln Alexander Wolters zeigt uns die
gut gefüllte Scheune
doch das Getreide stammt nicht aus
Sachsen es kommt aus Wolters Ländereien
in der Westukraine dort bewirtschaftet
er 4.200 Hektar Land wegen des Krieges
kann er seine Ernte dort nicht mehr
verkaufen
wir haben hier jetzt Mais den wir in der
Ukraine 2022 produziert haben den haben
wir aus von unserem Hof in Ukraine
hergefahren und versuchen den jetzt hier
vernünftig zu vermarkten das ist
aufwendig und teuer Wolters lässt das
Getreide in big Packs verpacken und mit
Speditionen anliefern in Döbeln kann es
zwischen Lagern vor dem Krieg war das
viel einfacher da ging seine Ernte per
Bahn oder Schiff zum ukrainischen
Schwarzmeerhafen Odessa und weiter in
die Welt vorbei durch diese extrem
Raketenangriffe Russlands sind die sind
die Leistung ist die Leistungsfähigkeit
des Hafens extrem in Mitleidenschaft
gezogen worden sie können den die die
Schiffe nicht vernünftig verladen und
auch wenn dort ein kurzer Stromausfall
herrscht steht die gesamte Kette und
vernünftige Verladung ist eigentlich
nicht möglich
der Getreidehandel sucht sich neue Wege
mit unerwarteten Problemen wir sind auf
dem Weg an die rumänisch ukrainische
Grenze unser erstes Ziel ist der kleine
Grenzort sirit ein Nadelöhr für die LKW
die stauen sich bereits 40 km vor dem
Schlagbaum in Richtung Rumänien
unterdessen meldet sich einer unserer
Informanten per WhatsApp ein Landwirt
der die enormen Auswirkung des
russischen Angriffskrieges beschreibt
guten Morgen hier ist Gordi Severing ich
bin amerikanischer Staatsbürger aus Iowa
und lebe seit 1993 in der Ukraine mein
Hof liegt nur 25 km von der Grenze
entfernt wo die Russen als erstes
einmarschiert sind er schickt uns Videos
mit seinem Kommentar
this
ein Getreidelager von den Russen gleich
zu Anfang des Krieges bombardiert
das Gebäude wurde viermal getroffen
durch Luftangriffe mit Raketen keine
Ahnung warum denn das Gebäude hat keine
strategische Bedeutung trotzdem wurden
wir heftig bombardiiert
besonders perfide der Getreideacker als
Kriegsziel
[Musik]
hat 120 Hektar es wurde im letzten
Frühjahr von Mint und ist es immer noch
bis heute
hinter mir sieht man einen
Sonnenblumenfeld der Acker misst 120
Hektar es gibt viele solche Felder in
meiner Region durch den Krieg ging den
Landwirten der Diesel aus deshalb wurde
das Getreide sehr spät ausgesät der
Ertrag war gering so dass der Landwirt
hier erst gar nicht geerntet hat
rumänisch ukrainischer Grenzübergang
dort treffen wir Igor aus der Ukraine
sein LKW voll mit ukrainischem Weizen
drei Tage steht hier in der Schlange
endlich hat er die Papiere sein Ziel
konstanter ein rumänische Hafen am
Schwarzen Meer
wir folgen ihm und mit uns zehntausende
LKW
zwei Tage dauert die Reise im Hafen
heißt es wieder warten
abends treffen wir Igor auf dem
Parkplatz
[Musik]
ich hätte nicht gedacht dass es so lange
dauert ich bin schon eine Woche
unterwegs seit ich meine Heimatstadt
verlassen habe an der Grenze musste ich
so lange warten allein der Papierkram
hat 24 Stunden gedauert
seine Kinder vermisst er am meisten
sagte und zeigt uns Bilder
mein größter Wunsch ist dass der Krieg
aufhört so schnell wie möglich heute
oder morgen
es ist wirklich furchtbar viele meiner
Freunde oder einfach Leute die ich kenne
mussten zur Armee und von denen sind
eine Menge nicht zurückgekehrt
am nächsten Morgen in konstanter seit
dem Krieg muss der Hafen zusätzlich mehr
als 8 Millionen Tonnen ukrainisches
Getreide umschlagen und das mit nur ein
paar Kränen und Silos der Hafen ist
völlig überlastet um ein Schiff zu
füllen braucht es 1400 LKW das dauert
dabei sollte die Fracht zügig von hier
aus quer durch Europa in die ganze Welt
transportiert werden ein Korridor der
Solidarität so nannte dass die
Europäische Kommission Klinge gut sei
aber nur eine schöne Idee sagt der
Geschäftsführer
die Europäische Union hat leider nicht
viel investiert ehrlich gesagt vor allem
nicht im Bereich der Logistik aber wir
hier in Rumänien hier im Hafen wir
strengen uns an und wir bewegen auch
etwas
sind begrenzt Investitionen überfällig
es gibt keinen funktionierenden
Bahnanschluss
marode Gleise und verrottete Waggons
die Folge ein Großteil des Getreides
kann das Land nicht verlassen nun
überschwemmen Mais und Weizen die
lokalen rumänischen Märkte das
Überangebot drückt die Preise das hat
Folgen
[Musik]
wir fahren nach Botosani im
nordostenrumäniens dort treffen wir
Franco popiniccio der Junge Landwirt
baut Getreide an für ihn ist das billige
ukrainische Korn ein wirtschaftliches
fiaskovic
seit Jahresanfang weil so viel Korn aus
der Ukraine kam
eigentlich sollte es Rumänien nur
durchqueren
leider aber fing unsere Händler an es zu
kaufen zum Lagern und auf den lokalen
Märkten zu verkaufen
pupin church hat viel in seinen Fuhrpark
investiert vor dem Krieg als die
Geschäfte noch gut liefen jetzt ist der
in finanzieller
Notar
aufnehmen um diese Maschinen zu kaufen
der Kredit läuft 7 Jahre jetzt sind wir
in einer schwierigen Situation und wir
brauchen Hilfe das muss nicht
notwendigerweise Geld sein aber
irgendeine Sicherheit
auch die rumänische Regierung wir sind
auf dem Weg nach Bukarest haben uns mit
dem rumänischen Agrarminister verabredet
wir warten darauf dass die europäische
Krisen Reserve jetzt aktiviert wird und
dass sie bei unseren Landwirten ankommt
wir müssen ihn jetzt Hilfe anbieten denn
sie sind in Not wenn jemand
welche Hilfe soll das sein was fordern
die Landwirte
wollen Geld sie brauchen Geld
angesichts der Schwierigkeiten in denen
sie stecken muss die notgelindert werden
und das geht nur durch finanzielle Hilfe
die erlaubt es Ihnen Ihre Arbeit in der
Landwirtschaft weiterzuführen
zurück zu Alexander Wolters der muss nun
den Rest seiner Ernte von der Ukraine
nach Deutschland bringen
was auf mich zukommt so dass ich mich
jetzt einfach vorbereiten muss für alle
Eventualitäten
seine ukrainischen Nachbarn müssen ihr
Getreide inzwischen auf den Feldern
lagern oder zu einem sportpreis
verkaufen das will Wolters unbedingt
vermeiden
und die nächste Ernte wartet der
Frühling hat begonnen
hier kann man ganz gut die Probleme
sehen die auf die uns zukommen werden in
der Ernte wenn uns die Mitarbeiter
eingezogen werden fürs Militär man hat
mittlerweile sehr viel Geld investiert
in gutes Werkzeug in gute Instrumente in
dem Fall gute Mähdrescher und die Frage
stellt sich natürlich ob ausreichend
Personal zu ernteverfügung sein wird
der Kampf ums Getreide für Wolters steht
seine Zukunft als Landwirt auf dem Spiel
für die Ukraine geht es ums Überleben